we understand Luke that you took four
years to work on Lord Montague right um
was there any way you could have made it
faster so it's funny the film started
out not as a film and actually started
out as an interview I was asked to go
interview this man who lived in this
castle his name is Lord Montague and I
was like absolutely okay I had no idea
what I was getting into and I went
interviewed him and he started telling
me his story and I just I just found it
fascinating and it was like why is no
one told this story and come to find out
the family and Montague himself had
remained silent about what had happened
to him and never spoke about it and for
some reason they started telling me the
story and I gained their trust and so
that took about a year to gain their
trust after the interview and then they
said okay you can make a film and being
in Texas every time I wanted to film
something I have to get a crew and fly
to England so I had to make every trip
very purposeful and so it just took a
little bit longer to to capture the
little story what kept you going during
the four years yeah yeah what kept me
going I just felt compelled that if I'm
going to tell someone's life story
someone were to tell my life story I've
want it to be the best and so I never
settled we actually almost stopped about
a year before we did and I just said you
know there's a few pieces of this that I
don't feel like we've captured or we
found and we kept going so I just wanted
to make sure that we uncovered every
possible stone there were there was an
ax and that it was the best story
possible when you began talking about
the infamous Montague trials did you
sort of put your toe in the water with
it or did they open up how did you
broach it because it was apparent even
in the filming that everybody was still
years later very affected by it
obviously I mean it took a lot like I
said took a lot of trust in time to
develop the trust for them to talk about
it and also a lot of people during the
trial art are dead there's not many
people to talk about it so you have
historians and then you have Montague's
autobiography you know his personal
feelings and then it was mostly
rave his eldest son who gave us a lot of
details because his he himself was very
intrigued but he himself didn't even
know what happened there Lord Montague
came to his children one day and said
here's this book I wrote read about it
Wow he didn't himself didn't even talk
about it so it was that close guarded
and so everything you see in the film is
absolutely everything that you're
possibly going to find out about the
trial there's nothing more there unless
you talk about Peter wildeblood who's
another famous character in the film but
as far as Lord Montague story yeah
everybody was just very reserved and and
it took a long time to push them and get
the details right well you talk about
Lord Monty you being a risk taker and
yes he started out on an incredible you
know footing that most of us don't ever
you know walk into that type of wealth
but he still it could have gone many
different ways that being said do you
feel that most successful people are
successful because of these extreme
risks he's an entrepreneur I mean
entrepreneurs take risks and he had a
drive within him where he was trusted
with something and it said you know this
is state and castle you were to carry
this on the rest of your life you know
this is you were to pass it on and he
felt it was his life's mission and I
yeah he definitely had that inside him
where it's like nothing is going to
stand in the way of that and so when he
was sent to prison and he came out of
prison he just said I'm not ever talking
about that because that's not the folks
my life this is my purpose and yeah he
just has an incredibly amount of energy
within him even to this day he's got so
much energy and always on the go and and
you could see that in the archival
footage he was a man on a mission right
right I want to give any spoilers away
but I definitely saw that it was
inspiring and there was a moment where
he said something interesting about like
I've already done this by eight o'clock
in the morning and yes wife kind of said
just just try being yes like but he does
that's all he does yeah but yeah looking
at risk what is the biggest risk you've
taken if you were to compare uh yeah I
mean I of course I didn't go to prison
or you know my life has never been
career has never been on the line but as
far as the filmmaker I would just say I
mean you know I was given the
opportunity to make this film and I
think it's very I was 26 when I started
making the film and I was trusted with
the opportunity and i was able to raise
the funding and i found myself in a very
unique and honored position where that's
very rare to be that young and a half a
story and money to tell the story so for
me it was a big risk to say for four
years i'm going to work on it let's face
it making documentaries you don't get
paid a whole lot of money so what you're
really into it for is to tell a great
story and so for me you know I there
were a lot of sleepless nights from
sitting in an editing you know room by
myself working on this thing and you
know my friends have never heard of
Montague no one in the United States
when the most part ever heard of this
guy so it's kind of like who are you
spending so much time making a film
about but I just saw value in the story
and I think that was basically that was
a big risk for me another risk actually
was coming out of college I studied
economics and I just moved to Austin and
I said I'm going to I'm going to be a
filmmaker and of course friends and
family around me so I had some talents
but I think everyone was kind of like
okay we'll see where this goes and so am
i find myself as a very monomaniacal put
blinders on kind of person and I saw
that in Montague I kind of found saw
little similarities there he's very
focused and one thing and nothing's
gonna stop I'm in and I felt like I'm
going to tell this story it it's me the
best it can be and nothing's going to
stop me sinem well you're also a
magician as is your father right how is
filmmaking like magic yeah filmmaking is
Magic yeah there are a lot of magicians
JJ Abrams for instance has a thing
called theory 11 a website about magic
and you know it's it's it's your when
you're given a film especially
documentary there is no script so it's
like this giant jigsaw puzzle and you're
trying to figure out how does it come
together and it's magic when you see
that come together in the Edit room you
know that it's just such a thrill in a
sensation and and it takes a lot of time
and developing your skill to be able to
be a filmmaker
just like magic in the same way you're
not going to go off and immediately just
do a card trick you know I remember I
started six years old doing magic and it
took you know I would practice hours on
end on one move one move over and over
until I could actually show somebody and
with a film you're always working so
hard for so long and then you finally
get to show it to somebody you know and
and so I think there's a lot of
similarities in the discipline and in
the unending creativity that they both
have are both pursuits isolating in some
way yes very much so especially
documentary filmmaking you don't have a
big crew you're a person wearing a lot
of hats and so you are in isolation
aligned that's something I've learned
about is how to make sure that we did
like eight test screenings of Montague
before it was done and I always was like
you know I'm not making a film for me
I'm too much in the weeds I need to
constantly screen this get it in front
of people's eyes and my small team is
about four of us you know we worked
really hard together to constantly put
it in front of people's you know eyes
fresh eyes all the time and but yeah it
is very isolating filmmaking especially
documented family can be very isolating
at times and that's that's definitely a
challenge let's talk about funding how
did you finance the film um well the
film so I was doing a commercial
advertising before I made this film and
I was asked by the head of this company
hey do you want to go interview a man
named Lord Montague he's actually my
uncle and he lives in a castle so that's
how the whole film came to be and so
he's a he's Lord Montagu's nephew and I
had to convince him after the Montagu
family gave me there okay I had to
convince him to make a feature let's
make a feature film about this guy and
so we actually went in steps he would
say okay how much more money and we come
up the budget at my team would we and
then he thought okay you can go I'll
give you this much more show me what you
can do so it was really proving ground
we'd go film we go edit something show
more and be like and he's a businessman
you'd be like okay I see the product is
getting better I see you know you're
still committed to it okay what's the
next step that's actually how it went it
was a very step by step
process and that's another reason why it
took so long it wasn't like here's all
the money you need go make a film I'd
never made a film before so is a very
hand in hand trust relationship but
you'd made short films and corporate
videos is that right yeah I made yeah I
had made I'd made one short film about
three minutes and one Austin's funniest
filmmaker I made it with the friend of
mine Bradley Jackson who co-wrote Lord
Montagu it was we made on a whim on a
weekend other than that I'd never made
anything longer than three minutes
everything else was corporate you know
internal marketing type things so of all
the footage it seems like you and your
editor I know I'm forgiving I'm drawing
a blank on his name your reign well I
edited Montague's oh you did okay I'm
sorry I thought you you had a gentleman
that edited with you I have to do a lot
of different things okay Wow all right
um so so much of the story did it was it
developed in that editing Bay since you
had all this footage yeah a lot of it
was Bradley Jackson when he wrote the
film with me and also sat in the editing
room with me a lot and it was very much
I would edit something show it to him
what do you think you know and he's he's
a narrative writer and so story
structure is very you know key and I am
and so it was it was a a lot of it
evolved in the Edit room because
Montague's life spans a hundred years if
you go back to his father which is part
of the film as well the history it's
just there's so much of it and it's
trying to make it a narrative form about
one man's life but he's involved in all
this history and how do you not go on
too many tangents for too long to keep
the audience engaged it was definitely a
balancing act how did you teach yourself
to make an actual feature film did you
go on youtube I watched a lot of
documentaries and then I I sought out
people that were older and more
experienced than me Doug blush is one of
them he's kind of a veteran in the
documentary industry i sent him a rough
cut he found it of interest i surrounded
myself with people that have either done
it been there done that before or who
have made films before not necessary
documentaries but films just so that i
could see i had litmus tests here and
there like half where are we going are
we in the right direction you know i
didn't just trust my own instincts which
in the end your instincts are very
important but
when you're working on something for
that long you need people around you to
guide you and and so I think that that
was a really big help ism I'm not making
a film for myself people have made
documentaries and films for a lot longer
of time so who do I find that can help
me and and so that yeah that was that
was really what helped me bring it home
and you were okay with the feedback from
the all that what you said eight
screenings I became obsessed with test
screenings and feedback the first test
screening I did was very stressful
sitting in the back probably drinking a
little whiskey by myself like just like
this is awful I don't know what the hip
but then I just I would tell people my
producer and I would say hey tell us
everything you don't like about this
film you know of course we want to know
what you like but also to make sure and
tell us what you don't like where are
you bored you know what characters are
not interesting game a whole list and I
would take all these lists and combine
them and look at what lines up and then
go through ok there's a reason for that
right let's address that let's tweak it
do another test screening what do you
not like about it and you normally hear
you know if you get 20 people in a room
there's a consistent voice that they
have about certain opinions and you
listen to that